[Music]
with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller Von Miller
[Music]
howdy guys I am Von Miller and this is
the first ever Vaughn cast
um presented to you by Bleacher Report
we're going to be coming to you guys
every single week
um throughout the season just to give
you my perspective through uh Bleacher
Report and this is the Von cast I'd like
to start you know my uh Von cast off
with a couple of tweets
see what's going on on social media
first we can start with this one by me
and it's uh my haircut
and it says uh Von Miller stock going up
I actually I can take a second to talk
about my haircut I actually started
doing this a very long time ago it's
probably like five years ago and it
started off real real small and it just
kind of like
developed into what it is today I'm from
Dallas Texas and you know we have a uh
the culture there when it comes to
haircuts where this fully Fades or uh or
or shags or or the South Side fade or
whatever man I've been doing crazy care
haircuts my whole entire life and I've
had this for a while it's crazy how I
got you know so much Pub right now so
since we're here we might as well talk
about it it started off you know about
six years ago with a little you know
itty bitty triangle and it just grew and
um now it has like a meaning behind it
it means uh three generations my dad my
brother and me also it means uh stand
neutral
or positive but never negative now I'm
just joking out I was just joking I just
came up with that man it's just my it's
just my haircut man and um I just wanted
to do something unique and here it is
it's me
yeah man my guy obj was at the game this
was the uh the uh Banner reveal in La
it's my first time back in La man it was
crazy man I thought about you know my
return ever since they started the uh
ever since they started you know the
schedule thought about my return back to
LA what it was going to be like how was
that gonna be receptive
um the reception was good man we dropped
the banner man it's my second Super Bowl
you know to do it with Odell man it was
crazy man I remember you know talking to
him whenever he got uh whenever the
Browns let him go I remember talking to
him like Hey man come come to La man we
we a team up you know we can go chase
this ring La is a place where we we've
obviously spent a whole lot of time even
before we played uh for the Rams and um
to have him there and go through that
whole run and to to say stuff and really
just talk it into existence way back in
November man it was cool man I'd never
forget my time in LA I'd never forget
any of my teammates never forget my time
with oh there his locker was right
across my mind and you know hopefully we
can you know running back here in
Buffalo
well what I'm doing this I'll be taking
questions from the chat as well so if
you got any comments you can put it
below and I'll check them out and I'll
get back with you guys as well
they said Von Miller Second Step you
know it's crazy going to this game I
have never sacked Matthew Stafford not
really think about it till after the
game
um played Matthew a couple of times I
got close but not actually a true sack
you know we played Detroit a couple of
times
um and I was I was super close but
coming into this game I honestly didn't
even think about second the quarterback
I didn't even think about sex I just
wanted to play the best possible game
that I could play for me and my
teammates whether that's uh getting a
sag a tackle for loss whatever it may be
a whole lot of huge huge expectations
you know with me being here for the
Buffalo Bills and I just want to live up
to that and it didn't necessarily need
to be a a sack but it definitely does
feel good to get a sack on your old
quarterback at your old stadium so it
was just a crazy experience man I always
remembered it never said it may do
Stafford before and we got him two times
to start the season I was good this this
uh tweet says I just want to point out
that I love the nickname Von Miller coin
for Josh Allen the creature
um I don't know I was just talking um
during my press conference whenever I
came here and it just happened like I I
was just thinking about you know
how tall he is and how range he is and
he can throw and he can run and it just
kind of like came up whenever I'm in my
press conference I you know I always
like to look at different perspectives
and I want to be on the media side when
I'm done so I always try to go above and
beyond for the media
so they can have things to talk about so
whenever I'm doing my press conference
I'm just open and I just talk to them
about you know what what state of mind
I'm in what I'm thinking about how I'm
actually feeling and I try to I just try
to make their jobs a little bit easier
because I can kind of see that
perspective on the other side and it
just happened like I was thinking about
Josh thinking about him running across
um the field and throwing it past to the
other side of the field I was like bro
like he's a creature man I don't know
what type of creature
um but he he definitely is and it
definitely goes through he's tough he's
strong you know he can run fast
um he's a great leader and he really
doesn't take anything serious I'm like
he talks with like this little Will
Ferrell voice man and it's it's so it's
so funny man and you know we we we all
follow his lead
um you know he's he's confident in
himself not a not an overly confident
thing but he knows that he can make any
play on that football field he's all
about winning and um yeah I'm happy to
be here in Buffalo with the creature
this says let's do a new NFL offseason
where Vaughn chooses chooses
um who's going to win the Super Bowl by
going to a new team every summer like
and make it like the bachelor's this it
didn't happen like that I always felt
like
I always felt like that I was gonna
um State let me start with that I always
felt like I was gonna stay with the
Denver Broncos and I was going to be a
Denver Bronco for the rest of my career
um I had
built my house up you know it was really
supposed to be like a forever home I
just never had the thought that I would
leave so when I went to the LA Rams it
wasn't my it wasn't about it wasn't my
choice I got traded to the Los Angeles
Rams so when I got there I also started
to feel like okay this is you know where
I want to end you know it's La I've been
going to La for 12 years made a lot of
friends there
um got to play with Aaron Donald like
Hall of Fame one of the best defensive
players that I've ever played with in my
whole entire career and I played with
some great ones and I had Leonard Floyd
and Jalen Ramsey and I had all these
guys around me and it was LA and it's
Delights and it's Hollywood I never
really thought that I would leave LA and
then free agency came
if your agency cave and it just kind of
happened that way like it was so tough
to leave La man even me thinking about
it now even after winning the first game
of the season like I still like you know
got a lot of love for La man and I'm
always thinking about like man like I
could have been in LA with Aaron Dunn or
like all the movie stars just you know
we really don't have we have one code
game that's going up to Seattle man it's
always good with the 49ers is always
good with the Arizona Cardinals man it's
just it just kind of happened that way
but this is a great idea man I I like uh
you know I like choose I like the
bachelor style they have all the teams
all the top teams and then the bun just
goes but I'm not I can tell you this
right now I'm not leaving Buffalo this
is a great place I love this place you
know we're gonna do some some special
things here and and I want to be a part
of it Dan feats
Von Miller is exactly what the the bills
Mafia have been missing over the last
two years
um man I don't I don't know man like
they had great rushes before me
um Jerry Hughes like I said coming here
there's a lot of expectation for me and
I love the expectation I love pressure I
feel like pressure is a privilege and um
to just leave the Los Angeles Rams after
winning the Super Bowl and to come here
and try to change uh you know the
history of this place and try to come
here and win the Super Bowl for you know
the Hall of Famers before me and you
know for my teammates that have laid the
foundation to be that last little drop
to to get over the hunt man it's great
man I just I just pray that I can you
know continue to to be the player that I
know I can be to be the player that this
this community needs me to be and be
this player that that um you know this
franchise needs me to be you know
football is football is tough you know
it's you know you win games and you win
by 21 and you know you make the plane do
backflips on the way home you know all
of that stuff man but football is a
tough sport it's a humbling Sport and
when you're thinking about like super
bowl or post-season success it's really
like drinking out of a fire hydrant like
it's just so much to absorb and um what
I really been preaching is just taking
it one play at a time one game at a time
um let's put it all out there and see
where we end up we're gonna have great
games but we're gonna be met with some
adversity too and when we get when we
get made with adversity those are those
are the defining moments of of actually
finding out what type of team will be
and I'm excited for those defining
moments I'm excited for the rest of this
season
and I am excited to bring in my very
first guest on the flying cast
it is Calais Campbell
um let me start off by saying he was the
2019 Walter Payton Man of the Year which
is the most prestigious award that you
can get in on that you can get in our
craft that you can get playing football
that you can honestly get playing sports
um you know it goes out to a guy that
has been so selfless and really poor
himself into his teammates in his
community and that's what Calais
Campbell has done you know winning the
Walter Payton Man of the Year I've been
nominated so I know how important it is
I wanted it bad you know and to um you
know be here sitting with uh Calais
Campbell one of my good friends with him
winning the uh Walter Peyton Manning of
the year in 2019 Miss humbling you know
he has more accolades to go with that
you know he's six-time pro bowler
2020
um Pro Bowl defensive MVP which that is
a great award too like to end the season
off being the MVP or the Pro Bowl team
is good too it's it really doesn't end
better than that um this is my brother
this is my friend he's helped me out on
so many different things he helped me on
my pastor of summit and now he's helping
me out with my uh podcast career this is
Calais Campbell how you doing bro
I'm blessed baby blessed happy to be
here man thanks for having me
yeah I appreciate you man let's we can
start off with some football stuff man
this this game this past weekend you
guys killed it man it was a defensive
great defensive game y'all had three
sacks you had one sack
um two or two assisted tackles and four
total man that's crazy bro how did it
feel to start off your 15th season with
the Baltimore raven
I mean I'll tell you what it felt good
man you know I wasn't sure if I was to
come back and play football I was going
to retire almost you know when I was
trying to go back to that process and
I'm glad I made the decision I came back
man I felt good out there man you know a
little sore you know you're 15 you know
I'm sorry you know you can get sore
after that but uh I had a blast man I
love this game it would be hard to walk
away when the time comes
man you know this is my 12th year and
when I'm in the locker room honestly
don't I don't feel oh like my mind
doesn't feel old and my body doesn't
feel old and honestly I hate saying old
in general I just try to keep my mind
positive but sometimes when I'm around a
young guys I could just like hear their
jokes and hear their perspectives and it
makes me feel like oh not not anything
on the football field and what I'm
watching it's just being around like a
totally different generation in the
locker room that is where I feel oh do
you do you feel those old in those
situations too
most definitely man especially when it
comes like to the music and like some of
this like they don't they don't
understand some of the pop culture I
grew up on like they don't some of them
some of them have like good Dads and
kind of taught them about like you know
Fresh Prince and Martin and like some of
the shows and like just like I mean you
know some of the movies that were
Classics I grew up on that they never
heard of it's like wow this is crazy
these dudes is young man 21 22 years old
that's crazy but you know it's it's cool
to be able to be that big Uncle to teach
them some things I try to put that good
information in there get them watch
certain movies and things like that
bring some culture to them it it is man
and um it is I you know I'll be in the
locker room and I DJ so I'm I'm the
controller of all the music in the
locker room and I'll play a song that
like gets me hyping it it doesn't it it
doesn't even have to be like you know
old school it could be like you know
early future early drinking guys are
looking at me like dang like you still
listening I'm like bro like these this
is this is music this is what you're
supposed to listen to before it games
and then I get there you know the
requests and it's just a totally
different generation it can be you know
NBA young boy which I'm a fan of all
these guys but you know the music is
just totally different the music that I
use to Get Hype is you know Future Drake
Lil Wayne and to these guys it's like so
foreign you know their musical taste is
totally different but you know I'll make
it happen I'll make it work you know I
just try to you know really absorb what
everybody else is listening to and just
put it out there
for so for so man I love being in the
locker room no place like it it's no
place like it man and I know you uh you
uh kind of contemplated retirement too I
haven't thought about retirement at all
but I know you got a son you know my son
just turned one I know you got a
two-year-old son Dakari right
yeah the car yeah yeah bro he's going he
looks he looks huge bro I know he just
got his first haircut you waited so you
waited two years to cut his hair
oh well I took to get a professional cut
I cut his hair on my own a couple times
you know just to kind of I don't know
what I'm doing really I never could have
myself before but you know he my son so
he gotta get messed up but I took him to
a professional barber finally had to get
him clean one time yeah you said he
Crawford you said he cried for 10
minutes before the haircut oh yeah oh
yeah he was crying at the first the
beginning of it he was crying Non-Stop
and then once like he kind of got
settled and realized it was gonna happen
he was just cool the rest of the way I
was like man that's cool every go see it
ain't that bad baby it ain't that bad
and it's cool I don't have hair like
that you know my my hair started doing
all type of weird stuff you know about
10 years ago so when it comes to my son
I really want him to have like long hair
like the braids so I wanted I want to
wait until he tells me that he doesn't
want her until he realizes like here's a
here's the uh the Instagram post right
here I want him to really
you know see what it's like to have here
and I want him to make the decision I
don't want to make this decision for him
but you know I want to be the guy to
take him to get his first professional
haircut too so when I saw this this
Instagram post man I I really felt that
one and whenever you get ready to retire
man you'll be able to spend so much time
I know in the off season me walking away
from my my son Valor man and going to
OTAs and coming out here
um to Buffalo for training camp was
tough he started walking while I was in
training camp
his mom sent me a picture of him walking
it just it made me feel like man I
really got homesick I was in the dorms
in Buffalo and I was like man what am I
doing man I'm supposed to be here with
him man and you know it's all for it's
all for a greater cause though I'm still
working I'm still trying to you know
create a future for my son man trying to
do more for him so I can I can
definitely um I can definitely relate to
you man about you know retirement and
spending more time with your son for
sure
yeah man I will say man uh yeah it seems
like he's he they grow up so fast and
like so many moments I already feel like
I miss but there's so many more moments
to be had you know he's only two so he
got plenty of time to have a whole lot
of moments so I'm gonna enjoy this
season who knows if there's future
seasons for me or not I don't know we'll
see how it goes but I I definitely
weighed down son waited to have my kids
so I was like almost done with playing
football but I do want to see him in the
locker room a little bit more give him a
little more football love but he's a big
boy hopefully he wants to play it we'll
see
yeah you got to get those you got to get
those pictures with your teammates man
you got to get the Lamar Jackson picture
man so he can have that man with Lamar
Jackson pop when Lamar Jackson go to the
Hall of Fame and all this stuff man
speaking of Lamar Jackson
you know he's going through contract
which we've all been through this you
know um he's going through some type of
I don't even know what it is because I'm
on the outside looking in and I always
just try to bypass the narrative because
I was on that side too and I know like
the media they pump this type of you
know nerve to say I turned down this or
I turned down that and I don't really
like to look at that I look at it this
way
the quarterbacks before him whether it's
um DeShaun Watson whether it's Kyla Mary
uh where there's Patrick Mahomes you
know all these guys got paid and it's
his turn like that's just how it is it's
it's his turn he's done everything he
could possibly do to put himself up to
have a to have a great contact a
contract that um jumps all of those guys
because that's just how it works you
know this guy gets paid this much and
it's just you have to carry the ball
higher and you have to do whatever it
takes to get there
um you can't take less you have to do
whatever it takes to get there to for
him
um to be out of those guys the highest
paid God because it's just it's just a
step it's just a it's just like a how do
I say the sliding it's like a it's just
like a little stepping stone like once
Colin Murray went here Lamar Jackson
goes here once DeSean Watson goes here
Lamar Jackson goes right here and it's
not about uh of course it's about unfair
production Lamar has done all that he's
been MVP of the league he's done
everything for his team to get this
contract and it just baffles me whenever
we have like these uh these stalemates
between player and the team
yeah man I'll say that he's very aware
he understands what he's supposed to do
he understands like you know whatever
else is getting the whereabouts is at
he's a smart dude you know I also think
he's confident he knows like hey man I
can play this game at a high level and
he knows he's capable of doing and so he
knows that the longer it takes for the
deal to get done the more valuable the
deal becomes you know I mean the
Market's always going up solid cap goes
up every year with deception of covet
you know it's been going up I think you
know pretty much 10 a year on average
for the past you know two cbas and this
next CBA with the TV contracts we just
signed it's about to go even more crazy
you know going up so um you know I mean
he you know he's a smart man he's very
aware and he uh you know to be doing it
by himself which is rare very very rare
yeah but yeah
you know a lot of guys get nervous with
that but you know I mean well I talked
to him a little bit I don't ever try to
get in this business too much I let him
do his own thing but you know just try
to see where he was at and I could tell
that he's a very very smart and
intellectual and he's you know he's
doing well for himself
yeah you got to get a guy props he's
representing himself
um he's betting on himself
um you know he's not you know he's not
dragging this all out in the media too
you know a guy like me if you know if I
didn't get paid on I'm not playing this
year I'm not I'm not playing this
I'm not playing this year I need my
money I'm did it you know and you know
uh props to Lamar man he's been very
very professional about this whole
situation you know he hasn't let it um
drag him down you know he's out there
he's out there playing he's out there
with his team you know every time they
ask him about it he kills it um I can
tell that he's a team guy playing his
team first at the same time he won
against this deal done and he's not
letting it you know affect his only
field play which that is the most
important thing because they want you to
take going through the contract
negotiation they want you to take a step
back so they can point that out like see
this is why or that is why and you know
he's still continuing to play at a high
level even with all this on his plate
even with all this on his mind man and
uh shout out to um Lamar Jackson for
sure
most definitely bro you know as I as I
stay in the league and I stay in the
league
um 12 years and these years just keep
adding up for me I'm sure you can say
the same you know I look at the player
safety you know side of things and you
know I've been through uh I've been
through two cbas now I've played through
two I played through two cbas and I see
the the type of steps that we take for
player safety and all this stuff and I'm
and I'm conscious of guys that are
coming up behind me I'm conscious of the
guys
um they come up after me and how could I
make the game you know better for these
guys and I saw um the Dallas Cowboys
game versus the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and
this this chip block went viral
um and we've all had these chip blocks
you you had a when we played uh the
Cardinals I think it was in 2000 I
forgot what it hey it was uh it might
have been two thousand and
12 maybe 2014 maybe where you got a chip
block where you got high low from the
outside and actually injured you and you
and you couldn't play the next week from
the high low and that that um that
sparked that sparked a rule change that
you can't have you know uh high low High
Low Blocks in the game before and this
is this is the uh chip block against
Michael Parsons which you know to
Lenny's defense like I love Lenny I
don't have any this is this has nothing
to do with Leonard fernet I'm not
calling him out he's he's doing
everything he's supposed to do he's
playing within the real within the rules
at this point
all I'm saying is
this block
it could have been done without this
much contact you know um you have to
think about play yourself you have to
think about player safety and these guys
are marquee Guys these guys this is the
future you know coming up like he's a
he's a defenseless player and everybody
I saw that I saw the comments on on
Twitter too that was like man what are
we doing with the game you got to make
yourself like I understand all of that
I'm just thinking about player safety if
the guy was on the line of scrimmage say
if we had him on a lot of scrimmage
that's all good you can chip him on a
lot of scrimmage like I can see you but
to come from the back side to come from
the um in the backfield up into chipping
to God mid-rush you know it's it's not
safe like I actually tore my ACL on the
play just like this so I've always been
conscious of the chip blocks that's why
Rolanda way outside of chill block and
I'll run the hoop I'll run the hoop and
I tell that three techniques to hit it I
tell them to get up the field and we can
run the text game we can do it that way
because I know how dangerous these
players this play can be especially when
I have all my focus on the offensive
tackle how do you uh how do you feel
about it
oh man I hate it you know uh I feel like
like you made a very valid point you
know uh the rule changes we're always
trying to make the game safer you know
being part of the you know exact
committee you know we don't really get a
lot of say so in the in the rules
Department we're trying to figure out
how to do that how to be more effective
in that world but this is something NFL
has to look at you know because you know
uh I mean I didn't know you told your
ACL on a chip block that's crazy but
when you think about it you know that
block I mean I've been in a situation
where I've got a trip like that where
you don't expect it to come and it
really I mean you put yourself at risk
you know and the one you saw about in
Denver man uh I mean when he Dove right
at my knee that's the worst I mean I'm
glad they got that out of there and they
put it where you have to at least they
uh stand up but even then you know like
if you're on a lot of scrimmage each
chip that's part of that's football
that's that's that's fair but when you
come from the backfield when we can't
see you that's not okay and um I feel
like you know the NFL you know I mean
we've been really big on trying to score
points and you know make rules for the
offense to be in a better situation but
I think we need to do some more for the
defense and it's that play that we
should get rid of and also that coming
back and cutting on the on the plunge
block or the cut block when the Tidy
comes back across the line of scrimmage
and Dives at the dn's legs man I just
felt like you know I'm okay with him
having that block it stays up but don't
come down lower to the knees with a full
speed a hand run especially with these
quarterbacks doing the Zone read stuff
because now we got to play all that and
so you don't get a chance to protect
yourself I think that they have to get
make the game safer for both sides of
the football especially on defense now
because so many of the past rules have
went to the offense
yeah and we we paying these guys like
bro like when it's when it's uh Michael
Parsons turn to to get his contract but
he's gonna get paid 50 55 million
dollars a year like what you want a
running back coming from the backfield
and chipping the guy and and throwing a
shirt out of place or Worse hitting him
in the head another play is what I
another play
um that I absolutely hate is when they
start to tight in opposite side and then
they motion them over to the opposite
side of the field outside the numbers
and right before they play they motion
them back in and he chips from the
outside on a lot of Screams he chips
from the outside waits for you to get up
field and he just depletes you that's
that it that is another place there's
nothing tough about that like it's
there's nothing tough about that you can
get that same block done by simply just
being in the way if you um for example
if it's an interception
changing Fields Sun change defense is
running down the field like we can't
just clean up offensive lineman we can
get in the way though we can get in the
way and slow him down and both um
chipping the guy crack blocking the god
during the interception and and just
being in a way they both get the job
done one is one is a whole lot safer
than the other one and that's that's
just what I'm all about especially for
these young guys man
yeah man we gotta just keep keep pushing
it in the media keep pushing it to the
lead and eventually get done and like
you said at the beginning of this is
making the game better for the young
guys because you know by the time the
rules get changed we're probably gonna
be long gone but you know making it
better for the guys to come after us man
that's important
100 I guess I got some I got some
questions for you from uh you know fans
in the comments they said so are you
going to talk about y'all's Alma Mater's
going against each other this Saturday
you know I was in that game when we
played y'all we came to Miami it was a
Thursday night game I think it was 2000
and maybe 2007 it was uh maybe been
Tuesday night game where we where we
came down there and we got stomped at
the at the old Orange Bowl
um but we playing you guys this week I'm
not sure if I won a bit I'm not sure if
I'm going to bed man we just lost the
Appalachian State man I'm not sure I
don't know I don't know what's going on
we give Appalachian uh State their
credit they always knocking somebody
else you know they did this to uh to
Michigan or their number one team they
did that to Michigan some years ago
they're always being top teams they have
a great football program
um kudos to those guys this hasn't has
nothing to do with the Appalachian State
football team I'm talking about the
Aggies how do we lose that game we had
playoff aspirations we had uh National
Championship after aspirations and it
just looks like all of that stuff will
have to wait one year we had the best
class the best freshman class to ever
come through college football and I'm
you know those losses like that hurt I
can see him I can see us you know
fighting a tough fight with Alabama
we're losing that like you can deal with
that but the one the Appalachian State
is tough so I'm not sure that I want to
to bet you on this Miami game coming up
because y'all got a great game too I saw
y'all put up 70 points on what team what
uh y'all put up 70 points first game of
the season you know Bethune cookman
though so it's a HBCU you know I mean it
ain't you know they don't got the
players to really be able to tank but I
don't know if y'all would have won that
game I'd have felt better about this
because now I come off a loss you know
just give you the extra Edge you need
like a bounce back game and I don't want
you to have no extra motivation no extra
momentum but at the same time you know
as you know if for us to be what we want
to be we have to be able to beat teams
no matter the emotion state they're in
so you know with you coming off of off
of loss you know I expect them to be
more locked in to be ready so we're
gonna have to beat them all y'all turfs
too in your Stadium yeah it's gonna be
tough
well
that's football
yeah it's gonna be tough man I'm a big
fan of what's his name TVD
uh is it Tyler I think it's Tyler
Van Dyke he's got some juice man he
could play football he does
I play in the Senior Bowl with DVD
DeMarcus Van Dyke so to see TVD and DVD
man it's crazy man Miami stuff
we gotta do something they gotta it
gotta be something it gotta be no money
or nothing we gotta do something you
know what you got in mind man if if the
Aggies if the Aggies win I send you an
Aggie Jersey wear for a day if the Miami
Dolph if the Miami Hurricanes win you
send me that that Miami Hurricane I I
posted on my story that's how we're
doing I'll put the Jersey on the story
but when the Aggies win you gotta do the
same thing and I the other song has to
be you know in charge of getting that
Jersey I'll send it to you I get your uh
I sent it to the facility so you can get
it done you my God man I know everything
for soul food man I'm gonna go ahead and
get that I'm gonna get everything lined
up cause all your normal boys Gradle
business so make sure it's there right
away
I I got you man it's gonna be a good one
for show man and you know before I let
you go man
um you know you had a uh a crazy career
man I've always looked up to you man
you've helped me out on so many
different things I just want to ask you
personally man what are your top five
plays in your career they don't have to
be sags don't have to be a specific
quarterback just tell me your top five
plays that you've made up until this
point
all right I'm gonna start with that same
game where I got hurt we saw my earlier
when uh uh Thomas hit me in my knee
before that I caught an interception on
Peyton Manning you know and I was crazy
I got tackled on the on the three yard
line by Peyton Manning too though but
still I don't care I picked off the goat
one of the goats you know and that's
cool for a d-line man we'll get many
times got hands on the ball so for me
you know we're gonna pick off yeah I
love that that's huge uh two you know uh
I remember like you know I grew up a Die
Hard Broncos fan because I grew up in
Denver and uh you know I remember uh the
Broncos beating you know um uh you know
Brett Favre you know in the Super Bowl
and I remember just watching Brett Favre
as a kid and and then being able to play
against them in the NFL was crazy you
know he's playing for the Vikings in 09
but I I had uh I told Coach I said Coach
man I just played like we we put in
earlier in that week and I was like yo
this if you call this place got work and
he was okay I'm gonna call next third
down he called it and saw my mind I got
to make it work and I'll be my guy
ripped inside grabbed Brett Favre like
suplex that's back where you can kill
quarterbacks I did get fined though he
said I did get fun
bro I think Brett Favre you know you
know he's a legend he got grew up
watching so that's cool
um when I went back to Arizona
and uh my first time you know I thought
it was Arizona Cardinal for life and I
ended up going to Jacksonville and you
know ended up being a blessing in
disguise because I had you know probably
my best my best season ever in
Jacksonville but we went back that year
uh you know my man uh unique way forced
to fumble and I scooped it and went and
I scored man and uh scored a touchdown
in that stadium and I wasn't sure if
they was going to boo me like you know
like seeing Seattle
Russell Wilson I thought that was crazy
uh but not the Arizona Cardinals I mean
they didn't boo man they showed me some
love I heard a whole lot of sharing in
there when I scored a touchdown now they
won the game so I think it's easier for
them uh for them for them to cheer but
uh it was cool to have the stadium still
show me so much love going back
um you know uh yeah then you know we had
a a game back in I don't know what year
it was but uh you know every time you
play against Tom Brady man it's always a
great game but I had a game where I
stacked him twice you know but there was
you know that first one you know why
they'll get them so second Tom Brady
that was that was huge and then um thank
God I mean there's so many great plays
but uh you know I'm gonna go back to the
like my first like big play uh and I
don't remember if it was Christmas or
Thanksgiving it was one of them like
holiday games playing against the
Cowboys and I was a rookie and um and it
was uh Marion Barber had kind of like a
little a little screen pass and he cut
back and he didn't see me coming and I
came through and I hit him with
everything I had he cut and he fumbled
you know coughed up the ball and uh we
ended up scoring and we ended up winning
that game and that was one of the
crucial players to win the game and it's
just like you know that was like when I
realized like I could be a star in this
league so that one that one felt pretty
good
man I appreciate you Brad I know that
must be tough for you to make so many
different plays man you've been blocked
you know um so many so many different
kicks
um you know you've done so many crazy
different crazy different things man and
I I know it must have been tough for you
to do that man but I appreciate you
doing it I appreciate you you know being
on the show always helping me out from
the past rest Summit
um to this show right here always
helping helping others out too
um watch a Peyton man in the year 2019
the most prestigious award and all of
sports that goes to my guy Calais
Campbell man and I want to say thank you
again man I appreciate you so much for
being on the show man you know my boy
yeah I appreciate it I appreciate it man
Rachelle thanks for having me yes sir I
have some end of show questions
you know from my from my guys in the
chat right here
um first question that says in honor of
your move to Buffalo
what is your favorite Wing spots oh oh
my God like
it's it's so many different crazy Wings
here like
man it's crazy bro I had to start off
with barbios barbios the honey butter
the Cajun honey butter barbecue wing and
I'm a chicken man I got my own chicken
farm I got you know um I know a chicken
I know I know how it's supposed to taste
I know the tech barbell and buffalo they
do an amazing job shout out Barbie I
appreciate you guys
um another question is is the goal this
season
getting the NFL side work I think that's
I think that's every season
I think that's every single season
um I think you want to go out there and
you want to break the safe record every
single year it's 22 and a half TJ watt
he um he tied it last year and I think
for every pass rusher every top pass
rusher that feels like he's one of the
best to ever play the game that's what
you that's what you're trying to get
every single year it might not always
happen
but I think that's always in the back of
everybody's mind
um says I played my o team in the first
game of the season this next question
says I played my old team in the first
game of the season and we won Russia
just played his old team and lost what
must he be growing through today
it's tough man and honestly I never even
thought about the idea of losing in uh
in La it was just that's just how my
mind works I never thought about losing
I never thought about losing to uh
um you know my old teammates in my old
stadium that just never crossed my mind
I always have positive self-talk and I
envisioned myself making plays I
envisioned myself of the crowd going
crazy
um I see the Super Bowl better I never
really put that negativity on my mind
but to speculate
knowing Russell Wilson I'm sure it's not
a big deal like this is the first game
of the season and um you got it out the
way they they had our very first game of
season going back to our old teams and
you passed it now you can not
necessarily take a deep breath but you
can just focus on football and not
necessarily the emotions that you'll be
involved in during the game the emotions
that you'll be involved in with old
teammates and the fans now it's just
football when football is already hard
enough so to deal with your emotions
going back this and that it makes it a
little bit tougher so I'm sure he's
relieved whether it was a win or a loss
that he can focus on his next team
coming up and he can have a successful
you know game this week because that
Denver Broncos team is gonna be good man
like Bradley Chubb turned it on man he
had two sacks in the second half
um Randy Gregory oh my God like his
speed to power move
is going to be deadly remember I told
you guys this like I'm watching The Rush
of course I'm watching the Broncos but
I'm watching The Rush Randy Gregory
um Brandon Browning
um Bradley Chubb Jonathan Coop man these
guys are going to have a good team and
you know sometimes the loss is great and
to to start the to start the season off
with a loss they're going to be
refocusing and be ready to go this week
and you can expect more of the Denver
Broncos expecting more out of out of
Jerry Judy Cortland Sutton this next
game I can guarantee you they gonna let
rest cook and he gonna be cooking with
Jerry Judy and Courtland Sutton all game
none of their little shakedowns and of
course they're gonna be there but he is
going to Courtland Sutton and Jerry Judy
all game long I can guarantee you that
another question is is how good can Josh
Allen be
this is probably the craziest question
on there because
we all know that Josh Allen is going to
be really really good it's going to be
excellent he does everything right he
doesn't take anything serious he has
this little Will Ferrell voice that he
talks with man it is funny man and you
know he has the talent to back up
everything he has a great
um a great Foundation of players around
him with his digs or or Gabe or you know
or Singletary this offensive line is is
a very very good offensive line we got a
great team over there and I feel like
Josh Allen
this is gonna be good he's got to be
good he's gonna be the MVP I just
surprised I told you that
um
next question is what what's the week
two song title
um we two song title I would have to say
this would be uh
bright lights on Monday nights
and I just came with that one on the top
of the head because we're playing Monday
Night Football versus Tennessee Titans
next this next question is how is the
chicken farm which I get this question
all the time first question I get is uh
are my glasses real
the next question that I get from
them to everybody is how's the chicken
farm doing and the chicken farm is doing
great
um I'm very blessed and appreciative to
have you know the team behind me you
know um shout out Paul and Shout Out
Cameron all those guys at greener
pastures chicken man I appreciate you
guys for you know helping me out getting
up off the ground and making this into
what it is today man I couldn't do it uh
without you guys I appreciate you guys
and the chickens are doing great
um this last question is
it's an easy one
y'all let me know down below who y'all
want to see on the show man anybody you
know I'm cool with everybody man whoever
y'all wanted to show man y'all put it
down below man we gonna get them on here
man we're gonna make it happen man I
appreciate y'all man it's DJ songs from
the gun this is Devon cast on Bleacher
Report I appreciate y'all and I'm
[Music]